entreprise à caractérisation et
l'évaluation des risques professionnels
des postes occupés par les femmes sont
probablement connus de tous au même
titre que ceux des hommes ils sont
évalués de la même façon en fait il n'y
a pas de spécificité de genre certaines
expositions sont même
connu pour être spécifiquement à risque
pour les femmes donc c'est le cas du
travail de nuit vous live souligné ou le
risque de cancer du sein chez la femme
est un risque identifié pour lequel la
surveillance du risque a fait l'objet
d'une recommandation de bonnes pratiques
qui a été labellisée en 2012 par la
chasse et c'est à peu près le seul chose
que
qui est un peu spécifique
il semble en revanche que les risques
professionnels dans les secteurs
professionnels plutôt féminin ne soit
pas suffisamment maîtrisé au regard de
certains secteurs plutôt masculins vous
avez cité de nettoyage c'est plutôt un
secteur très féminin
de même les spécificités liées au fait
que le poste soit occupé par une femme
sont pas suffisamment perçus sauf dans
le cas précis de l'état de grossesse ou
de l'allaitement ou le lien entre santé
exposition professionnelle chez la femme
alerte presque systématiquement les
employeurs et donc les visites chez les
médecins du travail sont souvent
déclenchés donc soit par l'employeur
soit par la salarié elle-même qui dans
cet état là on va dire va se signaler
et non dans ces cas là des aménagements
de poste sont en généralement
préconisés et sont généralement non plus
pas contester ce qui est ce qui est un
peu important
par contre il y a pas suffisamment c'est
vrai une prise de conscience de
spécificité telles que les spécificités
anthropométriques ou physiologiques des
femmes dans la conception par exemple
des postes de travail
aujourd'hui il poste de travail peuvent
être occupés aussi bien par des hommes
et par des femmes
et cependant voilà les les conditions
dans lequel on crée aujourd'hui les
postes sont souvent normés du coup sur
des sur des des mesures masculines et
donc ça ça peut générer par contre des
maladies professionnelles par exemple en
milieu de production la conception de
lignes de montage ou de production
prennent pour référence entre pays
métriques des mesures masculines ainsi
les postes de travail sont souvent en
plus non réglables donc elles sont peu
adaptées au gabarit des femmes et ça
c'est un risque d'apparition de TMS par
exemple
autre exemple dans la logistique
exposant en port de charge et où le
travail se féminise de plus en plus
l'organisation du travail et la
conception de des postes ne prévoit pas
de rendre tous les postes accessibles
aux femmes en s'adaptant à la différence
du corps des femmes par rapport à celle
des hommes donc une taille plus petite
une force musculaire plus faible un
centre de gravité plus bas des un poids
moindres un débit cardiaque inférieur
ainsi les femmes en logistique sont
souvent religieux à des postes on va
dire de premier échelon à forte
manipulation manuelle donc du picking du
copaking de l'emballage elles sont
souvent moins productives ou en limite
physique lorsqu'elle les occupent des
postes d'imasculins et donc ça perturbe
aussi leurs évolutions de carrière qui
sont limitées et moins rapide que les
hommes et ça les expose on va dire
d'autant plus aux risques de TMS
notamment puisque moi on peut évoluer
dans le milieu de la logistique et plus
on exposé au risque
alors on constate aussi qu'au fil des
années l'organisation de la prévention
des risques professionnels dans le
secteur professionnel plutôt féminin ne
soit pas la hauteur des actions qui ont
pu être engagées dans des secteurs
d'activité plutôt masculins perçues
comme plus pénible comme le BTP par
exemple en effet le risque accidentogène
et de maladie professionnelle grave
engageant le pronostic vital comme
exposition à l'amiante à la silice dans
des activités très masculines ont plutôt
attiré le regard de toutes les autorités
de contrôle et ont poussé du coup les
entreprises à s’engager dans de la
prévention et dans la maîtrise de ces
risques professionnels en comparaison
les risques professionnels du secteur
ducaire ou du nettoyage ont pu être
banalisés dans leur appréciation par les
employeurs et par les salariés eux-mêmes
au regard de ce qui a été fait tout chez
ces secteurs là
particulièrement aussi on peut souligner
que dans ces secteurs l'organisation
préventive donc le repérage l'analyse de
risque et la prévention a eu du mal à se
mettre en place faute de moyens
notamment dans la fonction publique
hospitalière au regard de ce qui peut
être fait dans le privé
et dans le secteur du nettoyage même si
des actions ont été menées par la
branche depuis ces dernières années pour
améliorer la prévention il reste encore
bien des choses à faire du point de vue
de la formation du personnel qui souvent
maîtrise pas très bien le français en
des recours de soins qui sont plutôt
parsemés d'embûches et qui ne
connaissent pas leurs droits en matière
de déclaration maladie professionnelle
ce qui peut expliquer aussi des formes
de sous de déclaration
au final la connaissance et la maîtrise
des risques professionnels ne fait pas
toujours l'objet d'une différence
d'évaluation selon le genre mais c'est
peut-être à tort et on peut légitimement
s'interroger de l'intérêt de le faire
notamment au regard des statistiques de
maladies professionnelles chez les
femmes que vous avez soulignées et
notamment dans certains secteurs et pour
mieux documenter et pour mieux prendre
en compte les risques professionnels
chez femmes au regard de leur
spécificité
[Musique]
il me semble qu'une étude statistique de
corde nationale permettrait des analyses
plus poussées statistiques pas secteur
d'activité par exposition aux risques et
ça serait certainement une bonne
proposition à vous faire pour
sensibiliser pour mettre aussi en place
des actions qui pourraient faire l'objet
d'une priorité d'action ensuite dans de
cadre de politiques plus globale tels
que les plans sentaient travaillent en
terme de politique santé en terme de
politique de santé au travail ou alors
au niveau de politique de santé publique
malheureusement aujourd'hui on sentait
au travail on va dire l'espacement des
visites médicales faites par les
médecins et le fait que certaines de ces
visites médicales
ne soient plus réalisé par les médecins
mais aussi par des médecins traitants
dans des secteurs très féminisés comme
le service à la personne ou le
mannequinat ça nous permet plus
tellement d'avoir on va dire une vision
exhaustive une vision globale de la
situation des femmes au travail
donc d'où le recours du coup à une étude
statistique nationale et plus globale
qui qui serait fait peut-être par par
santé publique France ou autre de façon
à pouvoir du coup analyser un petit peu
mieux ce qui se passe ou par un
laboratoire de recherche type Inserm
ce qu'on peut aussi préconiser pour
mieux connaître le
l'étude du travail des femmes ce serait
des études ergonomiques qui seraient
centré sur l'analyse d'activité du
travail des femmes et qui permettrait
également de mettre en évidence la
nécessité de réviser certains
référentiels de conception de poste par
exemple de travail afin qu'ils soient
bien adapté
autant aux hommes qu'aux femmes que
l'évaluation des risques professionnels
n'est pas genre à l'exception du travail
de nuit et
du risque du cancer du sein comme je
vous les ai dit mais sur la base de
données scientifiques qui pourraient
venir dans certaines activités serait
certainement pertinent d'inclure la
dimension du genre au sein du document
unique d'évaluation des risques qui est
le document de référence du coup de
l'évaluation des risques professionnels
en entreprise
enfin les campagnes de sensibilisation
ciblées auprès des femmes permettraient
aussi de mieux les informer des risques
spécifiques encourus au travail mais
aussi de les inviter à mieux repérer et
à mieux consulter
lors des premiers symptômes évoquant des
pathologies professionnelles et aussi ça
pourrait limiter le risque de sous
déclaration que l'on peut légitimement
suspecter
donc la façon dont le médecin du travail
aborde la question de la santé des
travailleurs sur le prisme du genre et
tout d'abord en visite médicale lors de
l'évaluation de l'équilibre du lien
entre la santé et le travail et dans la
dimension santé on retrouve les aspects
de santé physique mentale et sociales et
prix à leur rencontre notamment des
spécificités anthropométriques de la
personne et l'adaptation de son poste
mais aussi la charge mentale en lien
avec le travail mais aussi avec la vie
sociale la vie familiale
la situation familiale
les salariés aidants et la capacité de
la salarié à préserver du coup des temps
de répit ou de déconnexion et des temps
d'activités loisirs notamment extra
professionnelle comme de l'activité
physique par exemple en cas de
déséquilibre des aménagements en cas
déséquilibre du coup de du lien santé
travail des aménagements de poste seront
donc proposés plus récemment les
médecins du travail s'investissent aussi
de plus en plus dans des actions de
prévention de santé publique et peuvent
être en relais de campagne de santé de
campagne de santé publique nationale
consacrer notamment des pistaches des
cancers notamment cancers du sein chez
la femme
lors des manifestations Adobe rose qui
sont très largement maintenant relayés
en entreprise
les aménagements de poste permettant
l'équipe du lien santé travail chez la
femme et le maintient en emploi sont
diverses et vont aussi dépendre du type
de poste de la personne et de sa
problématique on peut envisager des
réductions du temps de travail sous la
forme du mi-temps thérapeutique ou alors
du télétrail dans le secteur tertiaire
pour les secteurs non tertiaires le
télétravail n'est pas possible donc on
peut envisager des réductions de temps
de travail des pauses plus fréquentes
des réductions de certaines tâches
physiques ou des postes avec de moins de
contraintes productives et moins de
pression temporelle et aussi penser à
des évictions de poste dans le cas d'un
risque d'exposition un des cancérogènes
mutagènes et reprotoxiques notamment sur
les femmes en âge de procréer
les aménagements sur le long terme
notamment lorsqu'il faut gérer
beaucoup d'événements d'absentéisme peut
poser parfois des problèmes de maintien
en emploi et on le constate
effectivement pour des formes assez
importantes de d'endométriose ou de
syndrome des ovaires polykystiques ou
alors dans des longs parcours de PMA
pour les cancers du sein nous n'avons
pas d'accompagnement différencier en
fait nous accompagnons nos salariés au
retour à l'emploi comme on le ferait
pour n'importe quel cancer mais il est
vrai que dans le cancer du sein plus
spécifiquement nous avons plus accès et
recours à des structurations externes
qui sont spécialisées dans ce type de
cancer et qui nous aide bien du coup à
réintégrer les personnes en entreprise
et à reprendre la confiance en soi au
sein de l'entreprise
et dans l'emploi
alors vous posiez la question des
transformations des organisations de
travail pandémique covid on constate
aussi effectivement une généralisation
des activités de télétravail qui sont en
général de l'ordre de 1 à 2 jours par
semaine en entreprise elle se régule
autour de ce de ce versant là les
nouvelles ces nouvelles organisations du
travail en mode du bride sont plutôt
plébiscités par les femmes dans nos
expériences car ça permet une meilleure
conciliation de la vie professionnelle
et de la vie personnelle et ça permet
aussi des économies de fatigue liées au
transport dans certaines régions
il est vrai qu'en pratique nous
constatons que les femmes ont des
charges et des responsabilités plus
familiales plus importantes que les
hommes notamment cas de séparation elles
ont souvent la garde des enfants toutes
les semaines de travail ces
responsabilités viennent parfois rendre
le véhicule du travail plus complexe
avec des ressources personnelles qui
sont affaiblies par la fatigue le manque
de temps de répit et le manque
d'activité sportif et d'activité loisirs
ceci peut expliquer des augmentations de
troubles musculo-squelettiques notamment
dans le milieu industriels ou des
risques de Burn Out chez les femmes car
ce mélange dans la genèse de ces
pathologies ou de ce syndrome des
composantes de risque professionnels qui
viennent se sur Ajouter à des facteurs
de vie personnelle qui engendre déjà du
stress et de la charge mentale et ceci
prédispose à la maladie
ce sont des facteurs que nous prenons en
compte dans nos consultations de santé
au travail et qui nous amènent à prendre
des mesures sur le travail et orienter
les personnes aussi vers des personnes
ressources telles que les psychologues
et les assistantes sociales qui nous
accompagnent dans nos services
les femmes accèdent aussi de plus en
plus dans le cas des politiques
d'égalité homme-femme à des postes à de
fortes responsabilités sans toujours une
égalité de moyens mis à disposition où
elle doit toujours faire leurs preuves
et elles n'ont pas non plus des
évolutions de carrière similaires se
pose aussi la question du risque de
Burnout dans ces situations parce qu'il
est difficile d'équilibrer sa présence
entre le travail et la vie personnelle
le choix et la renonciation sont souvent
admis au quotidien dans l'esprit des
femmes
quand tout va bien c'est de se faire
quand tout va bien dans les deux sphères
personnelles et professionnelles ça va
bien mais il suffit qu'une de ces
sphères se dégradent pour engendrer très
rapidement
des phénomènes de décompensation avec de
la frustration de l'anxiété et glisser
très rapidement dans des syndromes de
Burn Out ou d'anxiété dépression merci
pour votre invitation il se trouve que
je suis aussi médecin du travail que je
professe dans un service que j'exerce
dans un service inter-entreprise et au
contact avec les populations certaines
populations que vous avez cité et
mon invitation m'a amené à me poser des
questions sur ma pratique en tant que
médecin du travail ma pratique comment
je prenais moi-même le genre dans
dans les conditions de travail et bien
ce n'est pas évident effectivement le il
existe un document unique d'évaluation
des risques dans les entreprises que
toutes les entreprises doivent
remplir et ce document depuis plusieurs
années doit prendre en compte le
caractère jean-ré des risques au travail
sauf que c'est très très difficile à
faire à discuter du genre dans les
conditions de travail des entreprises
parce qu'on tombe tout de suite dans un
caractère discriminant et que notre
notre travail est justement de maintenir
au travail des femmes sans forcément
sans justement parler d'une spécificité
de femmes qui pourraient les discriminer
beaucoup en parlaient
les deux personnes auparavant parler du
travail de nuit il est emblématique que
en 1987 il y a un article du code du
travail qui interdisait le travail de
nuit aux femmes dans l'industrie et en
2009 pour l'égalité le travail de nuit a
été réintroduit pour les femmes
l'autre un autre petit exemple
historique du point de vue du travail
des cancers des femmes les femmes qui
étaient les épouses des travailleurs de
l'amiante ont été exposés du fait des
nettoyages les tenues de travail donc
elle n'était pas sur les directement
exposés mais il a fallu reconnaître
comme un collatéral accident de travail
accident maladie professionnelle pour ce
sujet
alors sur ce je continuerai avec la
connaissance des pathologies au travail
des femmes alors il se trouve que dans
mes activités je fais partie du coq et
du cnpst ou sont présentés des
statistiques sur sur les maladies sur la
branche ATMP un moment où on parle de
des statistiques donc il a été montré en
2019 que les femmes le taux d'accident
des femmes diminuait moins que le taux
d'accident des hommes qui diminuent
mieux est particulièrement bien et
l'assurance maladie donc la branche
Athénée nous a montré ce résultat et on
a dit oui d'accord et comment cela se
fait-il et il se trouve que les
statistiques genrés par branche par
métier par exposition existe pas donc on
n'a pas eu la réponse et il paraît que
c'est compliqué parce que c'est quand
même c'est des statistiques très très
importantes sur toutes les branches sur
tous les risques mais pas j'en ré donc
le problème du genre se pose et voilà on
n'a pas eu la réponse et c'était
difficile de
de l'explorer de même
il a été cité le Plan Santé Travail le
Plan Santé Travail 3 comportait un volet
sur les femmes et le croque de Bretagne
a réalisé une enquête sur le travail des
femmes le croque c'est le comité
d'orientation régionale des conditions
de travail à réaliser une enquête sur le
travail des femmes alors le travail des
femmes tout à fait descriptif les femmes
comment elles sont arrêtées qu'est-ce
qui est touché qu'est-ce qui est bon
mais maintenant on espère que en 2023 on
va passer à la santé parce que pour
l'instant c'était descriptif comment les
femmes étaient plus étaient moins donc
les femmes bon elles sont plus exposées
aux maladies les hommes aux accidents
mais les hommes ils sont plus exposés au
facteurs de pénibilité ils ont des
métiers plus à risque
tout ça se finalement est assez
compréhensible assez connu mais on
espère ils ont l'intention paraît-il de
continuer à leur travail on espère que
ça débouchera sur la santé des femmes
de même il y a une enquête en 2018 de
l'assurance maladie sur les affections
psychiques liées au travail et c'est une
enquête qui portait de 2000 ans à 2016
et il a été noté que les dépressions
chez les femmes étaient plus importantes
de l'ordre de 66% avec un pic à 44 ans
de même 60% des femmes sont touchées par
le burn out évidemment les secteurs sont
ce que vous avez cités médico-sociaux
transports
les situations déclenchantes étaient
soit un événement brutal soit un
événement révélateur de conditions de
travail donc il y a un facteur
environnement de travail qui est qui est
à mon sens spécifique dans les femmes
comment analyser
alors
j'introduirai le sujet par une
profession particulière que vous avez
cité les mannequins donc c'est
représentants de la féminité c'est leur
physique et leur âge qui est qui a une
importance dans cette profession et je
vous cite deux points
ce qui est bien documenté c'est les
troubles de l'alimentation chez les
mannequins et il y a eu une
un article du code du travail qui a dit
que les mannequins pour pouvoir profer
pour pouvoir exercer devait passer une
visite médicale tous les ans justement
et avoir un certificat médical qui
interdisait au mannequin anorexiques de
de professer
donc le mannequins anorexique oui mais
pourquoi l'anorexie
c'est bien de dire bah vous travaillerez
pas ça serait quand même plus
sympathique de dire pourquoi vous êtes
un Aurélie
de même les mannequins qui sont des
professions que l'on perçoit comme
privilégié
et c'est une profession qui violente
parce que cette violence de l'apparition
physique fait que les mannequins
travaillent entre 16 ans et 35 ans et
ensuite sont renvoyés à leur âge et sont
précarisés fragilisés parce qu'elles ne
trouvent plus de travail les mannequins
sont des intérimaires elles sont prêtées
par des sociétés qui pour faire des
photographies pour faire des défis
d'où encore on travaille ou on travaille
pas c'est le c'est la société
utilisatrice qui choisit donc il y a des
pressions et des agressions sexistes des
des violences sexistes qui sont
appréhendés dans un contexte mais un
contexte qui est pas j'ai à faire un
pervers narcissique ou
un petit copain mais
pourquoi le système a toujours accepté
ces violences pourquoi le système ne les
dénonce pas pourquoi le système ne les
prend pas en compte donc il s'est
violent de ces violences faites aux
femmes vous savez vous puisque vous avez
travaillé sur les RPS et les troubles
musculoosquelettiques vous savez très
bien vous avez appris que les violents
les risques psychosociaux entraîner ces
troubles musculus squelettiques et quand
j'entends que les femmes sont plus on
décrivent plus de troubles muscleuses
qui étaient plutôt il convient de
s'interroger sur ses violences subies
dans les dans ces professions donc j'ai
cité cette enquête cette cette
profession des mannequins parce que les
mannequins sont suivis dans un centre
exclusifs qui surveille tous les
mannequins de France et ils ont décidé
justement de cibler sur une enquête sur
cette profession en trouvant que elle
était comme elle était c'était une
profession justement qui était
maltraités avec des violences donc une
enquête et est en cours dans ce centre à
partir de cet exemple emblématique je
pourrais élargir au métier du car au
métier de la personne au métier des
ménages ou on retrouve ces mêmes
violences
ce sont des femmes qui sont précaires
avec des métiers peu rémillaires à temps
partiel avec des violences qui peuvent
survenir du client puisque c'est cité
dans les violences tout ce qui est en
rapport avec la clientèle peut provoquer
des violences des exigences de
l'employeur parce qu'il y a des pertes
de contrats quand on travaille dans les
métiers de l'aide à la personne à
domicile la personne peut décéder ou
être hospitalisée il y a plus de mais il
y a plus de travail donc c'est au bon
vouloir de l'employeur qui va donner ou
non qui va redonner un contrat ou pas à
la personne qui travaille bien qui a
accepté de faire des heures
supplémentaires qui a accepté de se
déplacer de travailler le dimanche
et elle sera assurée d'avoir plus de
travail que celle qui pour d'autres
raisons va peut-être le refuser
l'environnement peut-être violent aussi
parce que ces femmes habitent des zones
qui sont assez éloignées de leur lieu de
travail et qui sont peu sécurisés et
comme les horaires sont décalés dans
toutes ces professions du cœur des
hôtesses de caisse
ça les amène à retourner chez elle alors
que l'environnement est pas sûr elles
peuvent aussi être agressés
donc toute cette violence
systématique systémique des femmes est
analyser parce qu'elle est le lit de
troubles musculo-squelettiques et je
dirais même plus elle est le lit de
l'usure c'est de ce sentiment d'usure
c'est à dire qu'après avoir été arrêté
après avoir un arrêt de travail et ça a
été noté pourquoi on a du mal à revenir
au travail mais parce qu'il y a ce
sentiment d'usure de difficulté au
quotidien de violence dans traf
ça je continuerai en faisant un petit
focus parce que je suis donc présidente
mais pour une confédération qui est la
CFE-CGC qui s'intéresse aux femmes et
qui s'intéressent au cadre et le vous
avez cité la pandémie et pendant la
pandémie la CFE-CGC avait fait une
enquête auprès des cadres sur les
conditions de management pendant la
pandémie et pendant
et avec un petit focus sur la parité sur
le genre et les femmes c'était plainte
que
les enfants étaient à leur charge c'est
elle qui devait s'occuper des enfants et
que le télétravail à domicile avait pas
été du tout été pensé avec des femmes et
des enfants et que ça ça avait été une
quelque chose qui était excessivement
dur
en tant que cFECGC nous avons choisi de
continuer à travailler sur le management
le management qui a été donc un
révélateur pendant la pandémie et nous
avons décidé de continuer à travailler
parce que le management intermédiaire
est un management qui souffre aussi au
point que les métiers du management ne
sont plus choisis ne sont pas forcément
remplies parce que il y a des
contraintes qui sont importantes pour
ces métiers qui sont compris entre le
top management et le manage et les
salariés et que ces contraintes
nous allons les étudier et nous allons
les étudier avec une vision que l'on va
que l'on va jeanrer pour voir comment on
va trouver pourquoi ces femmes sont plus
exposées au risque de Burn Out quel est
ce côté systémique de violence qui fait
que les femmes sont plus exposées
au burn out voilà donc et l'objectif
c'est d'avoir un guide sur les bonnes
pratiques de management et de tout bon
donc en résumé il existe dans le travail
des femmes une maltraitance
organisationnelle qu'il convient de de
travailler plus en profondeur pour ne
pas s'arrêter à des cas individuels ne
pas s'arrêter à ben c'est la faute du
manager puisque nous travaillons sur ce
sujet donc pour nous et dans ma pratique
travailler sur les risques sur les
facteurs de risque sur les facteurs de
risque psychosociaux sociales et
absolument déterminant pour pouvoir
avancer sur ces sujets qui donnent une
qui quelque part font que
toute la santé des femmes est impactée
par cette
usure mentale cette violence et et ses
sentiments
merci de m'avoir écouté
merci beaucoup madame Chartier donc je
vais essayer de la parole à Magalie
Chevassu qui est psychologue du travail
et membre du réseau présence merci pour
cette présentation complète madame
madame la Présidente Mesdames les
rapporteurs je vous remercie d'avoir
souhaité entendre la voix de ma
profession et j'espère la portée de la
manière la plus juste possible je
remercie également chaleureusement le
docteur leteux de présence nationale qui
m'a transmis l'invitation et l'ensemble
de mes collègues qui a bien sûr
contribué à compiler ces arguments pour
vous alors comment prendre en compte la
santé physique et mentale des femmes au
travail alors tout d'abord très
rapidement quelques petits propos les
chiffres que je vais vous présenter bien
évidemment c'est un échantillon infime
de la population générale donc il serait
pas être représentatif de cette
population le psychologue en santé au
travail n'a pas accès à une immense
partie de la population parce qu'elle va
bien parce qu'elle n'en voit pas
l'intérêt parce qu'elle est orientée
ailleurs vers d'autres professionnels ou
parce qu'elle est en désinsertion
professionnelle donc on a forcément pas
accès dans nos locaux aux personnes qui
ne travaillent pas
les propos que je vais soumettre à votre
écoute donc sont à entendre comme des
hypothèses de travail ou en tout cas des
constats empiriques issus d'une pratique
et non des conclusions vérifiées et ces
constats ne présupposent d'ailleurs pas
de la part dîner ou d'Aki dans les
comportements masculins et féminins
alors sur la ismt13 qui est le mon
service alors c'est une un service
inter-entreprise
qui comprend 13110 entreprises
adhérentes pour un total de 165 000
salariés sur ces salariés
47,5% sont des femmes donc on a une
proportion finalement à peu près égale
homme-femme en revanche les cartes creux
sur la population des cadres puisque 40%
des femmes
occupent ces fonctions là ce qui dénote
quand même un écart important en ce qui
va concerner les inaptitudes sur les
cinq dernières années les chiffres sont
assez stables même très stables on est
plutôt sur 65% d'inaptitude prononcé sur
des femmes alors certes chez nous il y a
un billet de recrutement puisque on
donnait de nombreux adhérents sont dans
le secteur de la grande distribution de
l'aide à domicile du nettoyage ou du
soin ou du médico-social donc on est sur
des secteurs qui sont de toute façon
très occupés par des femmes ça peut
contribuer à expliquer une partie des et
pas juste de dire que les femmes le seul
argument n'est pas que il y a les femmes
souffrent plus en tout cas on a un
échantillon on a aussi parfois des
femmes qui sont très représentées dans
les secteurs qui sont difficiles et
usant
sur ces inaptitudes alors global 40%
sont prononcés pour troubles mentaux et
du comportement c'est comme ça que la
nomenclature le dit réellement qu'est-ce
que ça veut dire ça veut dire des
troubles anxieux souvent pour les femmes
des difficultés à gérer la pression
managériale parce que le travail est
dénigré parce qu'on leur fait des
reproches sur l'organisation personnelle
parce que il y a une remise en question
de leur capacité au travail
ces chiffres corroborent un petit peu
nos orientations vers la cellule de
prévention de la désinsertion
professionnelle puisqu'elle vont
concerner
beaucoup de femmes en tout cas à partir
de 35 ans on est sur 60% de femmes
orientées vers ces services de maintien
en emploi
alors sur les consultations
psychologiques maintenant on a une
proportion homme de salariés qui sont
orientées vers les psychologues qui est
très équivalente à celle qui se
saisissent de la démarche et ça
correspond aussi à ces fameux 65%. donc
finalement on a deux tiers de femmes
qu'on oriente faire les psychologues et
deux tiers de femmes en consultation moi
je note quand même un fait intéressant
c'est à dire que lorsque les personnes
ne viennent pas à mon bureau mais que
c'est moi qui vais dans l'entreprise
cette fois-ci c'est des hommes qui
viennent me voir
j'y reviendrai un petit peu plus tard
en consultation en tout cas sur la
population des cadres je note que une
femme sur quatre
occupe un poste de cadre et un homme sur
trois
occupe un poste de cas donc on a un peu
moins d'encadrant dans les consultations
donc
et là aussi je vais y revenir un petit
peu plus tard ce que je remarque aussi
sur nos chiffres
issus de notre service c'est que les
femmes viennent beaucoup plus tôt alors
comment interpréter ces chiffres et
c'est comme ça que je vais chapitrer mon
intervention d'une part des modalités
particulières d'exposition au risque
psychosociaux d'autre part des modalités
particulières d'expression symptomatique
il existe également dans le travail des
spécificités liées aux représentations
sociales de la femme et des spécificités
liées au poste à responsabilité
alors je me permets un petit rappel sur
les risques psychosociaux l'idée étant
de bien souligner que dans la prévention
des risques psychosociaux l'enjeu n'est
pas seulement de diminuer les facteurs
de risque mais aussi d'augmenter les
facteurs de ressources puisque c'est un
finalement un savant équilibre entre
l'existence de facteurs de risque qu'on
reconnaît mais aussi l'existence de
facteurs de dans lesquels on va pouvoir
puiser de l'énergie de la satisfaction
qui vont nous permettre de ne pas
souffrir d'une situation de travail en
revanche si les facteurs de risque sont
trop représentés là bien évidemment on
voit apparaître l'ensemble de ce qu'on
appelle les troubles psychosociaux que
sont le stress le burn-out les conflits
les troubles addictifs à viser
d'adaptatif les TMS etc
alors les troubles les risques
psychosociaux pardon sont définis par
Michel golach comme des conditions
d'emplois des facteurs relationnels et
organisationnels susceptibles
d'interagir avec le fonctionnement
mental dans le détail on a quelques
grandes familles qui reviennent et qu'on
va analyser notamment l'intensité et le
temps de travail soit les exigences de
la tâche et de la performance alors dans
cette famille de facteurs de risque ce
qu'on va remarquer chez les femmes ce
sont les temps partiels plus fréquents
mais qui ne sont pas forcément corrélés
à une baisse de la charge de travail il
est très habituel de voir une femme qui
travaille sur un poste à 80% par exemple
mais qui a une charge de travail à temps
plein parce que l'employeur n'a pas
forcément les moyens de prendre 20% pour
combler ce temps de travail tout
simplement c'est souvent le cas
d'ailleurs au retour des congés
maternité où on prend un congé parental
avec une diminution du temps de travail
mais on n'a pas une diminution du
travail qui est associée
les rythmes de travail sont par ailleurs
très exigeants dans les secteurs dit
féminins les hôtesses de caisse la ligne
de caisse fonctionne doit fonctionner
quoi qu'il arrive les toilettes par
exemple dans les dans les milieux
médicaux
tout ça est bien évidemment couplé avec
une charge mentale il y a l'organisation
familiale
sur la deuxième famille de facteurs de
risque qui est l'autonomie et la marge
de manœuvre alors on a de toute façon
une proportion moindre d'encadrante ce
qui veut dire aussi que sur une on a
plus de femmes en position subalterne
qui n'a pas forcément de possibilité
d'être concerté sur son travail de
participer aux décisions qui vont
impacter son travail et donc le
sentiment d'être un petit peu plus à
l'étroit dans un cadre de travail auquel
il va falloir s'adapter
les secteurs d'activité par ailleurs
féminin comprennent en général des
procédures qui sont lourdes des
protocoles des des manières de faire les
choses qui sont très encadrées des
produits à utiliser pour le secteur de
l'entretien avec finalement peu de
latitude pour conseiller peut-être autre
chose une autre manière de faire ce sont
également des secteurs où on remarque
peu de possibilités de parcours
d'évolution ou de reconversion
sur la famille des conflits de valeur
des conflits éthiques alors c'est une
famille qui est très enfin qui est très
exposée en fonction du niveau de
responsabilité ou du secteur d'activité
notamment les secteurs du Caire qui vont
faire qui vont amener les salariés à
faire face à la souffrance ou en tout
cas aux difficultés des personnes
on est dans une potentialisation de ce
risque là alors je remarque pas
forcément une différence en termes
d'exposition dans cette famille de
facteurs de risque moi ce que je
remarque en cabinet c'est une différence
au niveau des conséquences sur la santé
je m'explique les conflits de valeur
ce sont des conflits finalement à
l'intérieur de moi il y a une partie de
moi qui défend mon système de valeurs
entre ce qui est juste ce qui est
mauvais entre ce qui est bien ce qui est
mal et une partie de moi qui fait un
comportement que je suis souvent obligé
de faire parce que mon travail me le
demande
ces deux parties de moi dans un conflit
de valeurs ne sont pas d'accord on me
demande de faire quelque chose qui va à
l'encontre de ceux en quoi je crois
il se passe à ce moment-là un mal-être
très particulier lié à ce qu'on appelle
la dissonance cognitive dont il va
falloir sortir problème c'est que c'est
assez binaire la résolution de la
dissonance de la dissonance cognitive
c'est soit je maintiens mon système de
valeurs mais là il faut que je trouve un
moyen de sortir de ce milieu qui le
maltraite soit jamais nage mon système
de valeurs de manière à justifier le
comportement que j'ai et bien les femmes
ça c'est mon constat ça ne regarde que
moi attaquer moi si c'est faux mais en
tout cas moi ce que je remarque c'est
que les femmes tiennent plus longtemps
dans cet état de conflit psychique
interne elle arrive plus longtemps à
faire des compromis sans forcément en
fait elles tiennent dans la négociation
avec l'employeur en essayant de défendre
un système de valeurs alors que
finalement un homme va peut-être plus
rapidement que claquer la porte ou plus
rapidement se dire bon bah oui
finalement je pensais ça mais finalement
c'est comme ça qu'il faut faire
les conflits de valeur sont alors soit
sont intensifiés ou intensifie le
problème de charge de travail énormément
dans les milieux médico-sociaux avec la
question aussi des TMS notamment par
exemple sur des questions de la toilette
on a des quotas de personnels on a des
quotas de toilettes par personne en fait
l'idée c'est pas tellement la charge de
travail qui va poser problème c'est le
la capacité à bien faire son travail en
particulier quand ça va impliquer
une conséquence sur quelqu'un une
personne âgée qui ce matin-là et
peut-être plus difficile à lever qui est
peut-être de mauvaise humeur plus
difficile à toiletter va forcément
impacter le rythme des toilettes et
on remarque en tout cas chez les
personnes qui soignent que c'est pas
tellement d'avoir à faire 10 à 12
toilettes en deux heures c'est de
pouvoir les faire bien
quatrième famille de facteurs de risque
psychosociaux les exigences
émotionnelles alors les exigences
émotionnelles c'est tout ce qui va me
demander en fait de travailler sur mes
émotions de faire en sorte qu'elle
impacte pas mon travail de pouvoir
rester neutre voire même jovial parce
qu'il y a des exigences même dans les
professions commerciales il faut pouvoir
être aimable et avenant
alors ce qu'on remarque c'est que ces
exigences là se cumulent avec les
exigences émotionnelles dans la famille
avec les soins qu'on va apporter à la
famille les femmes d'ailleurs sont plus
souvent en statut des dents on parle pas
juste aux soins des enfants
la fièvre accompagnée chez le médecin on
parle aussi aux soins du parents âgé
soit un parcours aussi des de la fratrie
handicapée
avec j'y reviendrai tout à l'heure des
différences d'expressions émotionnelles
chez la femme et chez l'homme
là aussi je l'articule avec les risques
TMS notamment dans les secteurs du soin
et la petite enfance parce que même si
ce sont des secteurs ou il y a des
appareils de portage qui sont tout à
fait opérationnels sauf que c'est
douloureux pour certaines femmes pour
les éducatrices pour les
aides-soignantes finalement de ne pas
pouvoir offrir la chaleur des bras et
même dans les crèches finalement ou
parfois certaines personnes qui sont
sous restriction médicale parce qu'il y
a des douleurs dorsales et d'autres
douleurs qui qui devraient les empêcher
de porter et ben c'est difficile de pas
être dans la dans le holding pour
reprendre un terme sur lequel je
reviendrai aussi un petit peu tout à
l'heure
cinquième famille de facteurs de risque
les rapports sociaux et la
reconnaissance au travail alors les
métiers dit féminins sont parfois quand
même peu valorisés il faut le dire les
métiers d'entretien la grande
distribution c'est pas c'est pas
folichon ce sont des métiers qui sont
reconnus comme usant et qui sont aussi
plus exposés au risque d'agressions
parce que justement pas forcément très
valorisé et puis les hôtesses d'accueil
les hôtesses de caisse
sont pas forcément toujours très bien
traités
il y a un manque de reconnaissance de
l'investissement dans le travail
beaucoup d'entreprises aujourd'hui parce
que c'est très factuel et c'est
peut-être plus facile reconnaissent
uniquement le résultat du travail sauf
qu'en fait très souvent ce qui importe
c'est la reconnaissance existentielle de
qui je suis bonjour madame comment
allez-vous mais c'est aussi la
reconnaissance du processus de travail
qu'est-ce que j'ai eu qu'est-ce que je
mets comme effort pour réussir à faire
ce travail à produire ce résultat est-ce
que j'y ai mis plus de temps est-ce que
je suis allée approfondir mes
connaissances est-ce que j'ai mis plus
d'implication plus de soucis émotionnels
et ça finalement c'est une partie qui
reste très invisible et qui peut faire
souffrir
j'en viens également aux problématiques
d'insertion alors des minorités dans des
milieux d'hommes finalement les femmes
qui exercent dans les milieux d'hommes
alors soit elles exercent le même métier
mais avec finalement pas mal de
remarques sexistes ou autres soit en
fait elles y sont mais sur des postes
administratifs donc très quelque chose
de très clivé
là on peut voir apparaître les questions
alors j'ai mis les guillemets à
harcèlement parce que c'est une notion
juridique et que au stade où les femmes
nous arrivent on peut pas forcément le
qualifier de harcèlement en tout cas pas
juridiquement par contre ce qu'on
remarque c'est qu'elles sont très
sensibles au manque de bienveillance
c'est à dire que le dans l'environnement
de travail on ne prête pas forcément
attention à l'impact de la manière dont
on va dire les choses de des propos
qu'on va choisir
et du coup elles vont être elles pour le
coup très concernés par voilà pourquoi
est-ce qu'on m'a dit ça comme ça de
cette manière là en choisissant ce mot
là
et j'en fais aussi à quelque chose qui
est peut-être plus alors
je sais pas si c'est plus féminin que
Max que masculin en tout cas les femmes
se comparent beaucoup entre elles sur le
milieu de travail et on voit des
conflits générationnels assez importants
entre les représentations des jeunes
femmes et le représentation des femmes
plus mûres dans le travail
et j'en viens enfin pour clore sur les
risques les facteurs de risque
psychosociaux sur l'insécurité de la
situation de travail des choses qui vous
ont déjà été rapportées au sein de cette
commission les carrières hachées les
interruptions pour grossesse et congés
parentaux qui peuvent porter préjudice à
la progression à la progression de
carrière
alors pour en venir au deuxième chapitre
de ma présentation sur les modalités
d'expression des symptômes les femmes en
consultation clinique ont une
particularité elles vont exprimer
beaucoup plus souvent de la culpabilité
elle pleure plus souvent aussi
elles mettent plus en avant en termes de
positif leur capacité d'adaptation et
leur esprit collectif le sentiment de
faire un travail utile et pour elle un
facteur d'épanouissement par contre elle
se sent étiquetée plus fragile c'est ce
que moi je mets en lien avec le fait que
quand je suis en entreprise c'est
peut-être plus facilement les hommes qui
viennent tout simplement parce que les
femmes se sont déjà stigmatisées et que
donc si en plus on va on va rentrer dans
la salle avec le psychologue on va venir
confirmer le fait qu'effectivement je
suis plus fragile
je reviens aussi sur l'analyse des
pleurs
[Musique]
qui pour moi est absolument pas le signe
d'une fragilité plus importante c'est au
contraire le signe d'une meilleure
régulation de des émotions et d'une
meilleure capacité à réguler ses
émotions elles sont moins bloquées à
l'intérieur et elles agissent moins sur
le long terme
en tout cas les femmes montrent des
compétences on va dire plus précoce et
plus précise en termes de repérage des
symptômes de stress elles savent mieux
si elles souffrent de symptômes
physiologiques du stress elles savent
mieux repérer les situations de ce qui
vont les stresser et les techniques qui
va falloir mettre en oeuvre pour éviter
ces situations ou pour y faire face en
général du coup elles sont plus à
l'écoute de leur corps et de leurs
émotions par contre ça contraste
énormément avec leur tendance à
prioriser les besoins de l'autre donc
elles vont pas venir en consultation pas
parce qu'elles ne sentent pas le besoin
mais parce qu'elle sentiront qu'il y a
d'autres priorités et d'autres personnes
à qui s'occuper les hommes en
consultation vont exprimer beaucoup plus
facilement des douleurs ou de la colère
ou de la fatigue ils vont venir plus
tard plus abîmés
en fait moi je pense que pour beaucoup
d'entre eux c'est tout simplement qu'il
y a des dépressions masquées qui n'ont
pas été repérées et c'est peut-être pour
ça qu'on nous les oriente moins pas
forcément parce qu'il souffre moins mais
parce qu'il le masque plus
eux en tout cas en honte de craquer
si vraiment on a un homme qui pleure en
consultation c'est vraiment quelque
chose je veux dire avec beaucoup de
tendresse parce qu'à chaque fois c'est
quelque chose de précieux qui nous est
déposé mais c'est attention je vais
pleurer c'est on nous prévient c'est
ils mettent plus en avant leur autonomie
et leur capacité à prendre des
initiatives et le fait pour de pouvoir
évoluer et pour eux un facteur
d'épanouissement
la banni de la banalisation des
difficultés par les femmes et plus
grandes si la famille est monoparentale
parce qu'elle se donne une interdiction
de faillir
ou si elles occupent une position de
cadre parce que là encore il faut
pouvoir rationaliser le stress qui fait
partie du métier ou en tout cas prouver
qu'on mérite le poste donc on y met
débouchés doubles pour montrer qu'on est
à la hauteur de la tâche
je conclus ce propos en parlant des
transformations psychiques profondes qui
sont inhérentes à n'importe quel
parcours de maternité que ce soit les
accouchements les adoptions les fausses
couches les parcours PMA qui sont très
laborieux les échecs
l'allaitement le sommeil du nourrisson
les pathologies du nourrisson les
pathologies liées à l'accouchement aussi
tout ça peut avoir un impact alors
positif ou négatif sur l'estime de soi
sur la confiance en soi sur le sentiment
de légitimité et d'efficacité
personnelle et tout ça va bien
évidemment agir comme caisse de
résonance sur les difficultés qu'on peut
rencontrer au travail soit en venant les
atténuer parce que si je me sens mieux
dans mes baskets parce que j'ai réussi
certains objectifs personnels je vais
pouvoir mieux tolérer ce qui se passe
dans mon milieu de travail et puis
inversement si j'arrive pas à accomplir
certaines choses je peux être très
sensible à des difficultés qui se
présentent à moi dans le travail mais je
veux dire c'est propre aussi au
messieurs
alors quelques remarques sur la
particularité du stress d'origine
psychologique c'est une double
appréciation en fait j'apprécie à la
fois de manière subjective la contrainte
qui met imposée et j'apprécie aussi de
manière subjective les ressources que
j'ai pour y faire face donc je peux me
tromper doublement je peux me tromper
sur la gravité de cette contrainte qui
m'est imposée et je peux me tromper sur
l'efficacité des ressources que j'ai à
ma disposition ce qui parfois amène à
des différences en termes de stress
ressenti parce que ces messieurs souvent
vont avoir tendance à quand il
ressentent du stress surévaluer la
contrainte qui leur est imposée alors
que à stress équivalent en fait la dame
va pas forcément surévaluer la
contrainte mais elle va sous-évaluer ses
ressources
encore une fois en lien avec la
conscience la confiance en soi l'estime
de soi des femmes
la santé psychique dépend de la capacité
à intégrer les expériences positives et
négatives et faire face aux défis avec
le sentiment d'être en capacité
d'affronter les conséquences
la nature humaine est essentiellement
multidimensionnelle et à l'implique de
traverser des phases de transformation
parfois radicale en fonction des étapes
de la vie et quid du code du travail et
de l'article l4121-2 alinéa 4 quand
est-ce qu'on adapte le travail alors à
l'homme non pas avec un petit âge
excusez-moi mais avec un grand H hein il
s'agit aussi d'adapter le travail à la
femme mais je j'ai un petit peu de mal à
le voir il y a quelques exemples quand
même mais mais trop peu à mon sens
enfin l'acceptation du vieillissement
est rendue beaucoup plus difficile
socialement pour les femmes que pour les
hommes c'est bien qu'on s'est bien
entendu une femme plus avancée dans
l'âge plus de chances d'être considérée
comme plus usé moins efficace alors
qu'un homme plus avancé un homme plus
avancé dans l'âge et plus expérimenté
plus outillés plus légitime etc alors
quelques représentations sociales
stéréotypées au travail pendant 3e
chapitre alors les femmes et les hommes
vivent une éducation émotionnelle en
tout cas pour ma génération encore
peut-être c'est peut-être moins vrai
pour les générations d'après très genré
les petites filles
sont pas forcément
entre guillemets autorisé à exprimer
beaucoup de colère on sent bien que la
tendue social est pas là en revanche on
légitime beaucoup leur tristesse on les
accompagne beaucoup et c'est peut-être
l'inverse total pour les hommes ou là
bon finalement il y a pas trop de
problèmes à ce que les petits garçons
soient en super mais par contre il
s'agirait quand même pas de pleurer
parce que sinon on aura du mal à devenir
un homme
bon heureusement ça change un petit peu
l'éducation pour les filles de manière
générale les plus protectrice alors
c'est très bien je n'ai rien contre ça
le problème c'est que en sous-jacent
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire ça veut dire
qu'on est que les femmes sont des
victimes potentielles et qu'elles sont
donc des proies dans un milieu de
prédateurs donc du coup peut-être que on
peut se poser la question les
hésitations de la femme plus importante
à prendre des risques que par rapport
aux hommes
autre question qui moi me titille ce
qu'on appelle la préoccupation
maternelle primaire qui est un état
presque fusionnel finalement de la maman
avec son petit bébé qui est censé
prendre naissance vers la fin de la
grossesse et prendre fin quelques mois
après l'accouchement
moi j'ai un problème avec ça ça a été
décrit par un homme comme une pathologie
mentale d'allure schizoïdes et
transitoire
et moi je me demande en fait et si
c'était faux tout simplement déjà est-ce
que est-ce que c'est est-ce que ce
serait pas faux que ces transitoire
parce que en fait finalement même quand
ils ont 25 ans les enfants je pense pas
que les femmes soient coupées de leurs
besoins
essentiels et si c'était pas une
pathologie mentale en fait et si c'était
ça la normalité d'être capable d'être à
l'écoute des émotions de l'autre et
d'être à l'écoute des besoins de l'autre
oui
la PMB la préoccupation maternelle
primaire voilà
et si c'était et si c'était ça qui était
normal en fait et si c'était ça qui
était inhibé chez les hommes cette
capacité finalement à être en connexion
à ressentir les besoins de l'autre et à
pouvoir y répondre si c'est juste
il y a également des attendus sociaux
autour de la vulnérabilité de la douceur
alors qu'ils font que la charge mentale
émotionnelle qui sont invisibles ne vont
pas entraîner de reconnaissance
particulière et donc dans les milieux du
cœur ça pose problème
il y a un paradoxe qui est énorme entre
oui effectivement une femme doit être 12
vulnérable s'occuper des enfants etc
mais en même temps on stigmatise les
femmes qui vont prioriser l'éducation
des enfants sur leur insertion
professionnelle et puis en fait tout
simplement on va dévaloriser la femme
qui est en position d'autorité et qui va
l'affirmer parce que du coup très
facilement c'est pas c'est plus
l'autorité légitime du manager c'est la
méchante puisqu'elle est pas censée être
ferme elle est censée être douce et bien
vite
donc voilà quelques paradoxes auxquels
les femmes font face et puis bien
évidemment aussi les attentes autour de
la maternité qui stigmatise les femmes
qui font le choix de pas avoir d'enfant
ou qui peuvent pas en avoir
les hommes à côté vont s'autoriser très
difficilement une forme de fragilité en
tout cas qu'ils estiment comme une
fragilité et puis il va y avoir des
stéréotypes aussi sur l'ambition et la
quête de pouvoir dans le sens où les
autoritarisme masculins vont être plus
facilement légitimés par les femmes un
patron qui me parle mal finalement c'est
pas forcément un méchant c'est juste un
patron
sauf si et quand même
il est dans une position de pouvoir qui
est perçue comme illégitime parce que il
a peut-être pas montré c'est cette
capacité à manager correctement ou parce
qu'il exerce son pouvoir par la
séduction ou la manipulation alors là
les femmes sont très très efficaces à
repérer ce genre d'éligibilité dit
légitimité de pouvoir
au poste à responsabilité alors le code
du travail indique implique en tout cas
des obligations de moyens et de
résultats de l'employeur vis-à-vis de la
santé de la sécurité des travailleurs
ce qui fait que le rôle prescrit du
manager
en termes de disponibilité d'écoute de
rôle protecteur contenant c'est une
posture de soutien ça c'est sur le
papier dans les faits dans le travail
réel la posture du manager c'est une
posture tournée vers la performance vers
la pression vers le contrôle la
vérification la surveillance la
transmission de consignes avec le fait
d'être garant de leur application et ça
pour le middle management c'est souvent
un vrai problème pourquoi parce que la
responsabilité sans les moyens d'agir
parce qu'on est d'accord que le middle
management il a pas forcément beaucoup
de latitudes il applique ce qu'on lui
demande d'en haut et il compose avec les
contraintes qui viennent d'en bas
qu'est-ce qui se passe je suis
responsable mais j'ai pas les moyens
d'agir je me culpabilise
alors la responsabilité la femme elle
sait faire la disponibilité la femme
elle sait être ça fait partie du bagage
féminin en revanche sur ces postes là la
femme anticipe très très bien la balance
gratification sacrifice quand même la
balance bénéfice risque pour employer un
terme peut-être plus à la mode
la femme va être sur ses postes là en
conflit sur les représentations entre la
compatibilité de la vie de famille et le
travail et moi je me demande pourquoi
parce que finalement oui certains le
cadre travaille souvent au forfait jour
etc mais finalement les milieux du Caire
les milieux de la grande distribution il
y a aussi très très peu de
disponibilités on est sur des travails
de week-end de soirée donc finalement
la compatibilité est vie de famille et
poste de management elle est pas
forcément moindre que dans d'autres
secteurs d'activité ou dans d'autres
niveaux de la hiérarchie enfin les
femmes ont un sentiment d'illégitimité
plus prononcé que celui des hommes sur
quand on leur demande leur opinion sur
ces sur ces postes là
alors quelques pistes de réflexion
puisqu'on parle du comment mieux prendre
en compte la santé des femmes au travail
je pense que il est aussi important de
changer le regard social pour pouvoir
changer le travail
question question ouverte l'encarant
doit-il être responsable du travail
fourni par ses collaborateurs comme
c'est le cas aujourd'hui où est-ce qu'il
doit être responsable des collaborateurs
eux-mêmes responsables de leur travail
dans le milieu du Caire dans le milieu
dans les milieux sociaux
peu de salariés travaillent pour leur
direction
en fait les salariés travaillent pour
leur public pour leur passion pour leur
résident
travaillent pas pour leurs peurs pour
leur direction leur direction et elle
est envisagée comme finalement quelqu'un
qui doit les soutenir qui doit leur
fournir les moyens adéquats pour bien
faire leur travail
et c'est pas ça qui se passe finalement
sur le terrain alors si on envisage que
le responsable doit être responsable du
collaborateur de son bien-être de sa
capacité à travailler on présuppose du
coup en recrutement qui n'est plus
uniquement sur une compétence juste
technique mais aussi sur d'autres formes
de compétences ça suppose aussi qu'il
faut amplifier les efforts de formation
des managers aux indicateurs de mal-être
à la communication excusez-moi il y a un
mot qui est parti à l'écoute et qui ne
soit pas axée sur la rentabilité avec à
la clé un vrai bénéfice secondaire sur
la prévention des risques psychosociaux
puisqu'on va gagner en latitude
décisionnelle et puis on va améliorer
les relations collaborateurs encadrant
dont on sait qu'elles sont pas les
meilleures
enfin plus on est au plus on est seul
évidemment ça c'est la forme de la
pyramide en bas on est des équipiers on
est un groupe on a un collectif et puis
plus on monte plus on est isolé alors
est-ce qu'on peut promouvoir la
transversalité des projets partagés ne
serait-ce que pour alléger pardon on la
charge cognitive décomposer les
problèmes complexes mais aussi
finalement améliorer il s'agit pas
tellement de de rendre de mettre plus de
femmes dans des postes d'encarant mais
c'est aussi sur ces postes là qu'elles
soient peut-être plus satisfaite et
mieux en phase avec leurs besoins et
pourquoi pas instaurer systématiquement
des partages de bonnes pratiques entre
encadrant pour renforcer un sentiment
d'appartenance de légitimité puisqu'on
sait qu'elle se sentir légitime
de diminuer la charge cognitive et de
renforcer le sentiment d'efficacité et
enfin je suis tombée sur une conclusion
qui m'a beaucoup étonné mais que
finalement oui je suis obligé de la
partager il y a
plus de chance pour les femmes de
bénéficier de promotion interne ça a été
noté dans un rapport de Ben David et
bameline de 2022 alors pourquoi en fait
et c'est vrai qu'en consultation moi ce
que les femmes me rapportent c'est que
si elles veulent évoluer on va leur
demander de changer alors de changer
d'antenne de d'avoir une mutation parce
qu'elle cône elle connaissent trop et
bon pourquoi finalement qu'est-ce que ça
implique de trop connaître ses collègues
est-ce que est-ce qu'on les manage moins
bien est-ce qu'on se fait moins bien
obéir je ne sais pas est-ce que c'est
pas tout simplement la peur du lien
peut-être la peur qu'une femme aurait
peut-être plus de chance à favoriser les
unes ou les autres sur des critères
émotionnels plutôt que sur des critères
de de
travail en fait pourquoi est-ce qu'on
pense qu'une femme est moins apte qu'un
homme
à bénéficier d'une promotion interne
c'est une vraie question le regard
sociétal et la confiance alors sur le
congé maternité
en France finalement il y a beaucoup de
femmes qui ont peur de se congé
maternité elles ont peur de pas
retrouver le même travail une fois
qu'elles seront parties et finalement il
est assez court
moi je contraste ça avec l'Allemagne
finalement il est très mal vu de revenir
au travail moins d'un an après
l'accouchement
pourquoi parce qu'en fait on investit la
femme d'une d'un rôle très important de
d'éducation de formation d'un futur
membre de la Société et que finalement
si on privilégie son travail et bien on
est un petit peu égoïste un petit peu en
marge des besoins sociétaux c'est pas du
tout le cas en France où finalement ben
non il faut vite vite revenir au travail
parce que sinon ça veut dire qu'on
s'intéresse pas à la société bon
pourquoi ne pas réfléchir au meilleur
encadrement des remplacements il y a
beaucoup de femmes qui reviennent de
congé maternité pour se voir attribuer
un poste différent
quel vivre comme une vraie dégradation
comme une vraie dévalorisation parfois
même c'est leur remplaçante pendant le
congé maternité qui va occuper leur
poste une fois qu'elle revienne donc il
y a vraiment une réflexion à mener je
pense là-dessus le renforcement du
soutien au maire allaitantes pourquoi
pas systématiser alors là je lance des
pistes comme ça systématiser les
conseillères en allaitement et pourquoi
pas les congés allaitement pourquoi pas
re rémunérer les pauses allaitement
alors j'ai trouvé du coup dans le cadre
de ses recherches une vieille
proposition de loi qui a été adoptée par
la Chambre des députés en 1913 où il est
stipulé qu'il est interdit de décompter
en aucune façon du montant du salaire
journalier leur destinée à allaitement à
l'allaitement qu'est-ce qui a fait que
ça a disparu c'est sûrement le progrès
la modern beaucoup de choses en tout cas
certes si on en si on voit les choses
sous l'angle économique l'allaitement
c'est absolument pas un temps productif
pour l'entreprise en même temps une
femme à qui on permet de remplir ses
objectifs personnels je peux vous
garantir que c'est une salarié hyper
motivée qui se sent très considérés et
qui se sont aussi très loyal vis-à-vis
de son entreprise
et puis sur vos parler aussi du risque
du cancer afin du cancer du sein on sait
que l'allaitement c'est quand même
quelque chose qui est reconnu comme très
préventif
sortir du paradoxe et donner les moyens
d'occuper le rôle des dents ou de
soignants alors on peut aussi soyons
fous donner aux soignants les moyens de
soigner mais en tout cas
d'aider les aides familiales ou les
personnes qui ont ce rôle là dans la
famille de pouvoir mieux le faire et de
renforcer les politiques de congés en
forme malade et dans familial le
maintien de la mutuelle lors du congé
parental intégral sur le temps de
travail il existe des entreprises alors
les plus grosses sont les mieux lotis
mais qui proposent des tranches horaires
d'arrivée de départ ce qui donne
beaucoup plus de souplesse dans
l'organisation
est-ce qu'on valorise la réalisation des
objectifs ou le nombre d'heures là aussi
c'est une vraie question comment est-ce
qu'on valorise ce qu'on appelle les
temps interstitiels c'est-à-dire en fait
les fausses posent il y a des milieux de
travail où la communication est
dysfonctionnelle on n'a pas le temps de
se transmettre des informations et ben
finalement on va utiliser les pauses
pour faire ça alors certes c'est du coup
très chouette parce que ça va fédérer
les équipes ça va réguler des émotions
mais c'est pas des pauses voilà donc on
coupe pas avec le travail et on allait
pas sa charge cognitive
favoriser l'éducation émotionnelle
précoce pour tout le monde mieux repérer
et valider ses émotions mieux valoriser
les soins préventifs en général et les
soins psychiques en particulier de par
les efforts de remboursement
renforcer la présence des psychologues
dans les structures de soins à la fois
pour les patients mais aussi pour les
équipes pour les aider à réguler leur
tension
quid des contrôles arrêt maladie moi en
consultation j'ai un vrai problème avec
ça des personnes qui ne me demandent en
fait des attestations pour être sûr de
pouvoir
donner au contrôleur sécu un papier qui
atteste qu'ils étaient pas en train de
se balader et encore j'ai envie de dire
même s'ils étaient en train de se
balader est-ce que c'est pas aussi la
possibilité d'avoir des expériences
positives pour sortir d'une dépression
ça c'est pour une vraie question
la prise en compte du genre dans
l'alliance thérapeutique ça aussi c'est
une question sans réponse est-ce que un
homme se confie plus facilement à un
homme sur un problème psychique ou
est-ce qu'il se confie plus facilement à
une femme et inversement
égalité rime avec équité et pas
indifférenciation on l'a assez dit la
question des retraites est-ce qu'on
récompense uniquement le temps qui est
générateur de richesse de richesse ou
est-ce qu'on peut aussi imaginer qu'on
pourrait récompenser les efforts de
cohésion sociale tout au long de la vie
les retraites aujourd'hui en tout cas
dans le débat qui qui nous concerne vont
impacter fortement les espaces de
transmission et d'entraide
intergénérationnelle que ce soit par
rapport à la gare des petits-enfants
mais aussi les soins aux parents une
femme de 65 ans a des parents qui sont
parfois très très dans une dépendance
très avancée et c'est souvent un point
crucial que de pouvoir leur apporter une
fin de vie digne dans un accompagnement
avec le sentiment d'avoir de rendre tout
ce qu'on a reçu de son parent et ça peut
être important
et enfin je me permets de clore là
dessus attention aux fausses bonnes
idées on sait qu'il y a déjà des
antécédents notamment dans
l'automatisation du travail le Voice
speaking où on pense alléger des choses
et en fait on crée de nouveaux problèmes
pareil pour les coupures dans le temps
de travail je termine là-dessus un
exemple
issu de ma pratique un petit supermarché
de province qui a vu ses risques
psychosociaux explosé à un moment donné
et suite à mon enquête en fait on s'est
rendu compte que c'est parce que on a
pour en voulant bien faire on a aboli
certaines coupures du Midi qui parfois
étaient très longues puisque c'était
quatre ou cinq heures
pardon sauf que du coup sur un métier
déjà peu valoriser ces quatre ou cinq
heures de coupure ça permettait le
mercredi d'économiser une garde d'enfant
ça permettait de passer du temps de les
accompagner au sport et ensuite de
revenir au travail et une fois qu'on
leur a enlevé ça cette capacité à
concilier une vie professionnelle et une
vie personnelle le seuil de tolérance à
d'autres difficultés comme les mauvais
rapports avec la chef caisse ou la
polyvalence avec le fait de voir aussi
aller
décharger des c'était plus toléré de la
même manière voilà je vous remercie
beaucoup oui
alors le Voice speaking alors oui non
mais au fait alors c'est quelque chose
qui c'est mon jugement de valeur ça ne
concerne que moi qui est très
déshumanisant en fait vous avez un
casque sur les oreilles et vous avez une
voix robotisée qui vous dit des numéros
toute la journée en fait qui vous dit
d'aller dans l'allée à prendre un
certain nombre de colis donc on vous dit
allez à deux et puis en fait vous vous
devez répondre en boucle ok pour montrer
que vous avez bien compris la consigne
et qu'ensuite vous avez fait ce qu'on
vous demandait de faire et donc toute la
journée vous entendez des chiffres et
vous répondez ok ok ok voilà et bon
c'est une façon de
transmettre des consignes qui te fait
gagner beaucoup de temps mais
merci beaucoup madame Chevassus pour
cette exposé très complet et donc je
vais me tourner vers la dernière
intervenante qui est Alice de Maximy
fondatrice du collectif femme de santé
premier collectif plus riche
professionnel de femmes qui ont une
activité dans le secteur de la santé qui
a récemment fait des propositions en
matière de santé des femmes au travail
dans ce secteur à vous madame je vous
remercie mesdames les sénatrices et
merci de me donner l'opportunité de
d'être la voix de ce collectif qui
compte 2700 membres
qu'on soit du secteur public ou du
secteur privé de la santé de l'industrie
ou qu'on soit aide-soignante on ne peut
parler avec une directrice de
laboratoire pharmaceutique quand on est
secrétaire médicale dans ce collectif
c'est important pour nous on a 50 hommes
dans le collectif qui est ouvert aux
hommes parce qu'on ne rétablit pas une
égalité de genre en en créant une autre
et la genèse du collectif c'est un
rapport du CSA qui a épinglé la santé
qui est présente les femmes uniquement
comme mère d'enfants malades
pas des postes d'experts et c'est tout à
fait la jeunesse du collectif le
collectif il a comme mission de qu'on se
construit un système de santé plus juste
plus équitable et plus égalitaire et de
faire avancer à santé par l'intelligence
collective pluridisciplinaire
grâce à la sororité j'ajoute qu'en tant
qu'actrice de santé publique à l'origine
pendant plus de 15 ans voire 20
et maintenant startupeuse un tel
collectif n'existe pas la santé elle est
cloisonnée au niveau du secteur public
et du secteur privé qui se déteste il
faut être franche parce que c'est la
vérité et de l'autre elle est cloisonnée
à cause d'une hiérarchie sclérosante qui
pèse aussi sur les conditions de travail
de tous et notamment des femmes et elle
est aussi cloisonnée par les secteurs
d'activité tant le chant est large et
donc c'est le seul collectif qui a
explosé ses cloisons là du coup
l'approche que je vais avoir va pas du
tout être celle que vous avez eu jusqu'à
maintenant puisqu'on décloisonne
systématiquement et on dézoome
systématiquement dans ce collectif
il est porté donc par la startup hkind
il n'a pas un statut associatif mais ces
orientations stratégiques éthiques
opérationnelles sont toutes discutées en
comité d'organisation qui regroupe des
femmes de santé de tous les secteurs et
un système de sondage en ligne permet de
définir les thématiques de nos travaux
donc en fait ça fonctionne de manière
plutôt démocratique
avant d'aborder le point fort c'est à
dire les travaux du collectif chouette à
retirer votre attention sur deux enjeux
de santé au travail que j'ai pu
percevoir ou qui m'ont été reportés par
les membres du collectif donc là je ne
fais pas un écho de travaux basés sur
des faits mais sur des des témoignages
qui ont pu remonter les femmes victimes
de violences intrafamiliales
représenteraient 10% des salariés et es
et les repérer et les aider au travail
est en faveur de leur santé mentale
les hôpitaux est une obligation de faire
des plans d'égalité un des hôpital a
créé tout un système d'accueil des
femmes victimes de violence salariés et
a permis de le remettre dans dans
l'emploi alors qu'elles étaient tout en
arrêt maladie
les remarques sexistes n'ont toujours
dans ce volet là les remarques sexistes
dans le secteur de la santé sont légion
maintenant avec la nouvelle loi beaucoup
d'entre elles sont considérées comme du
harcèlement c'est extrêmement fréquent
et c'est dû aussi à une cloisonnement au
niveau de la hiérarchie de qui commande
dans ce secteur là c'est à dire que
notamment dans le public les directeurs
d'hôpitaux ne sont entre guillemets par
nous le dire aussi crûment pas des chefs
des médecins et des pôles soignants du
coup c'est un peu compliqué c'est un peu
le système de l'éducation nationale pour
les collèges
des patrons sont pas les directeurs
d'hôpitaux donc du coup ça crée vraiment
des vrais enjeux ou quand ils veulent
installer une politique claire soit en
santé soit en RH ils ne peuvent pas s'y
la CME ne passe pas ne passe pas et s'il
déjà une volonté des soignants dessus
donc ça c'était pour le premier point un
peu pour faire un volet sur sur ce qui
se passe et puis le deuxième c'est c'est
pas de chez nous mais je me fais écho et
si vous les auditionnez je me tais tout
de suite je peux pas vous donner le
document puisqu'il m'a été donné de
façon non-officielle enfin officielle
mais non diffusable la MNH la fondation
de la MNH la Mutuelle Nationale des
Hospitaliers a fait une revue de la
littérature internationale sur justement
ce qui se passait de la santé et de la
femme dans le secteur professionnel de
la santé donc la santé des
professionnels de santé il ressort
effectivement qu'il y a d'énormes enjeux
de santé reproductif et sexuelle des
problèmes de la grossesse les problèmes
de la grossesse ils sont dû
effectivement un taux de fausse couche
supérieur à la moyenne mais il y a un
autre enjeu aussi qui ressort
c'est qu'en fait comme on a du mal à
recruter des soignants dans le secteur
hospitalier privé au public l'annonce
d'une grossesse est un vrai problème
puisque le poste n'est pas remplacé donc
vous imaginez bien que du coup les
conséquences et de là je vous parle de
statistiques pour le coup pas de choses
qui m'ont été reportées sans que par
exemple les femmes internes ne font pas
d'enfants puisque leur stage est reporté
donc elle perdent en ancienneté et elle
travaille vraiment à un poste plus tard
et même les femmes reculent leur moment
de maternité voire ne font pas d'enfants
donc c'est un point important parce que
et c'est dû aussi c'est vrai une
perception de ce qui est fait d'avoir un
enfant mais c'est surtout dû au fait que
comme les postes ne sont pas remplacés
une personne qui part en congé maternité
ça crée un trouble dans le service qui
est déjà hyper tendu
voilà donc ça je vous invite vraiment à
je peux demander à vous fournir cette
étude de la MNH je pense qu'il est
extrêmement intéressant parce qu'elle a
été faite au niveau international elle
montre vraiment ce qui se passe là où il
y a un gap dans ce genre d'études c'est
dans toutes les études qui ont été
faites c'est qu'on a complètement oublié
les aides-soignantes
et l'autre endroit où il y a un gap
c'est qu'on oublie toujours parce
qu'elles ne sont pas des employés à
proprement dit de l'hôpital mais quels
sont payées par des prestataires de
services en contrat ce sont les femmes
qui apportent les plateaux et qui font
le ménage à l'hôpital et elle elles ont
des conditions de travail déplorables
mais on en parle jamais et leur
profession est au moins à 95% féminine
donc juste j'attire votre attention on a
0 donné là dessus
alors un petit préambule avant de parler
des travaux on parle beaucoup de
discrimination
on parle de discrimination positive
juste pour rappeler qu'en anglais on
parle d'affin d'affirmative action c'est
pas du tout la même perception la
discrimination positive le terme
discrimination serait peut-être à
enlever de ce point-là en santé on parle
d'équité pour plein de raisons et ça
c'est acté en tout cas par tous les
personnes qui œuvrent dans la santé et
qui travaillent sur la santé de la femme
en décembre dernier on a organisé des
États généraux des femmes de santé où il
y avait plusieurs centaines de personnes
les États généraux chez nous ont comme
objectif de trouver des solutions utiles
pratiques et concrètes à de grands
enjeux de santé et cette année le thème
choisi était la santé de la femme
l'année dernière je ne résiste pas au
fait de vous le dire c'était la place de
la femme dans le secteur professionnel
de la santé vous imaginez qu'on a trouvé
énormément de solutions qu'on a
identifié énormément d'enjeux je vous en
parle quand vous voulez
un petit rappel méthodologique sur ces
états généraux d'abord on fait une revue
de la littérature grise française c'est
à dire les études qui sont qui ont été
publiées qu'on peut trouver en ligne
on en extrait les problématiques qui
existent on les présente aux femmes de
santé et les femmes de santé
identifiées avec nous des grands enjeux
sur lesquels elles veulent travailler
qui répondent au panorama qu'on leur a
fait à cette synthèse de la revue de la
littérature 14 ateliers collaboratifs
ont été créés l'événement a eu lieu le 9
décembre 30 solutions ont été proposées
et données au cabinet ministériel de la
santé de l'égalité de la fonction
publique et une lettre ouverte au
pouvoir public signé par 700 personnes a
été écrite pour créer un institut
national santé de la femme qui serait
publique privée à but non lucratif on
est en train de s'accrocher pour trouver
la structure juridique qui porte qui
aurait comme objectif de porter une
stratégie nationale santé de la femme
qui n'existe pas
et ça nous a paru absolument incroyable
que ça n'existe pas
à noter aussi il n'existe pas de
parcours de santé de la femme en dehors
de la maternité du cancer du col et du
cancer du sein il y en a pas on parle de
parcours de santé parcours de santé
c'est la prévention le soin le poste
soin c'est l'ensemble de ce qui concerne
la santé de la femme alors on l'a
travaillé ce jour des États généraux je
vous en parlerai une autre fois
éventuellement mais à titre d'exemple
concrets saviez-vous que les petites
filles sont traitées plusieurs années
après les petits garçons quand elles ont
un retard de croissance
de croissance
et on sait qu'il est important de donner
en mode croissance au bon moment ça
c'est un exemple tout à fait concret de
ce qui se passe actuellement à la santé
on n'avait pas du tout du tout du tout
perçu ça avant de faire cette étude de
la sainte vue de la littérature pas du
tout on avait des échos et les femmes de
santé nous demander de travailler dessus
et on s'était pas posé la question du
tout et on a découvert qu'il y avait
tellement de trous dans la raquette il y
avait tellement d'inégalités il y avait
tellement de choses qui n'avaient pas
été faites qu'on n'a pas été capable de
dire mais sur quel sujet on va
travailler et du coup on a organisé un
atelier qui avait comme objectif de
réfléchir à quel sujet on allait
travailler dans ces états généraux
le thème des États généraux précis et
inégalités de santé chez les femmes
brisées les paradigmes mais proposer une
approche positive vous allez comprendre
pourquoi très vite ce qui est ressorti
de cette synthèse que je peux vous
envoyer
c'est que si on n'a pas compris que tout
tourne autour de la charge mentale des
femmes du sexisme intégré des tabous et
des biaisés alors on n'a pas du tout
compris ce qui se passe dans la santé de
la femme
et c'est ça qu'on a identifié et on a pu
démontrer par les études que la charge
mentale est responsable 1 de l'accès aux
soins et de l'accès à la prévention or
si on parle de prévention des
préventions tous qu'on propose je viens
de PES juste pour préciser donc je suis
une fan de prévention et pendant des
années je me suis moi la première fois
voyez tout ce que nous proposons en
prévention notamment pour les femmes
alourdies la charge mentale donc elles
ne vont pas dans la prévention puisqu'on
leur propose une prévention qui est à
l'origine alourdine à charge mentale et
donc on tourne en rond en fait dans ce
circuit de prévention et c'est ça qu'on
a découvert on a découvert ça pourquoi
parce qu'il y a ne serait-ce que trois
ans même si de 85 l'idée on parlait à
peine de charge mentale encore moins de
charge mentale dite médicale maintenant
qui est en gros que la femme si elle a
une famille va penser au rendez-vous de
tout le monde sauf des siens et donc
elle va pas aller faire ses dépistages
et autres d'autant plus qu'en plus
derrière on parle de s'ils sont
dépistage est positif et qu'elle a un
cancer on va parler de cancer irritable
car vous pouvez dépister tôt vous
imaginez quoi de la culpabilité des
femmes d'avoir un cancer évitable parce
qu'elle est pas allé se faire dépister à
temps donc voilà donc ça c'est juste un
peu qui se passe un peu dans et c'est ce
qu'on a trouvé donc je vais avancer un
peu les freins donc à cette prise en
charge en fait d'être bien soigné ou de
prendre soin de sa santé sont en
deuxième exposition à charge mentale en
première l'argent
l'argent et on sait que les femmes sont
plus précaires etc etc donc je reviens
pas sur ces démonstrations là donc ce
sont les deux points on s'est retrouvé
face à ça avec cette notion de tabou qui
revenait toujours en fond toujours et
encore avec cette notion de banalisation
des symptômes avec cette notion de
maladie totalement inconnue de tous avec
cette notion de maladie mixte mais qui
ont des spécificités féminines on s'est
dit mais qu'est-ce qu'on fait qu'est-ce
qu'on fait de ça on a décidé de
travailler en amont des États généraux
sur deux grands ateliers faire en sorte
que les préventions les préventions
primaires secondaires et tertiaires ne
soient pas perçu comme des contraintes
supplémentaires mais un moyen de lever
la charge mentale des femmes quelque
chose qui n'a jamais été fait dans la
santé jamais été pensé comme ça on s'est
dit objectivement on va dire voilà on
entre femme qu'on était un peu folle de
partir là-dessus qu'on y arriverait
jamais et pourtant on l'a fait et le
deuxième point c'est la littératie en
santé ou comment donner la bonne info le
bon choix au bon moment d'autres termes
comment les trouver les tableaux autour
de la femme la charge mentale je vais en
venir à l'enjeu du travail
30 solutions donc et je vais vous en
citer quelques-unes en préalable juste
la charge mentale la grande confusion
entre la charge mentale et la santé
mentale on l'a eu on l'a eu pour plein
de raisons et donc on parlait parfois de
santé mentale parfois de charge mentale
les deux sont intimement liés en fait et
covid pour ne pas le citer puisque vous
nous posez la question à démontrer et on
le sait et à alourdi en fait à alourdir
la charge mentale des femmes mais a
aussi indirectement puisque on a vu déjà
dans les dans les les discours tout à
l'heure qu'il y avait une une différence
entre les hommes et les femmes qui a été
montré dans une étude notamment une
étude Suisse que on n'avait pas du tout
la même façon de percevoir
nos risques le traitement et
l'interprétation du stress n'est pas la
même là je parle d'études voilà les
convictions de pouvoir maîtriser son sa
son existence elle est moins marquée
cette conviction chez les femmes
et en plus on ajoute à ça de plus faible
revenu donc c'est compliqué plus pour
les femmes que pour les hommes c'est
comme ça et la perte de l'identité du
rôle sexuel on en parle trop peu
l'infertilité la ménopause les
expériences d'avortement tout ça font
que en fait on a plus de vulnérabilités
à ce niveau là et donc si on ajoute à ça
la charge mentale et ben là on passe du
côté santé mentale donc c'est toute cet
enjeu donc on ne peut pas faire fille de
la charge mentale en santé publique en
fait mais jusqu'à présent rien rien rien
n'a été pris en compte en santé publique
dans les dispositifs de prévention
concernant la charge mentale à part sans
doute pour la médecine travail où vous
en tenez compte mais dans le quotidien
et dans l'ensemble des politiques
publiques la charge mentale elle passe à
la il n'y a pas un seul indicateur de
charge mentale dans tous les dispositifs
qu'on propose
du coup on a fait plusieurs
recommandations je vous cite au niveau
de la charge mentale recommenciation qui
concerne les employeurs donc nous allons
dans le milieu de travail et je vais
parler et pardon la médecine du travail
donc je suis très heureuse de vous
rencontrer mesdames parce qu'on a des
choses à discuter
nous proposons que les préventions
soient mises en place sur le temps de
travail voire organisé par les
employeurs
et tous les employeurs qui ont été aux
États généraux étaient d'accord et
certains le font déjà certains ont une
journée de congés dédiée à la prévention
voilà comme ça au moins c'est clair
c'est cadré en d'autres termes
d'accorder du temps de santé prévention
Adam les accords des salariés et faire
venir et faire venir les préventions aux
femmes donc soit on accorde une journée
soit on prend les rendez-vous parfois
les femmes ne veulent pas c'est pas
toujours si simple soit on fait venir
des gens sur le lieu de travail pour
faire des campagnes de vaccination par
exemple donc ça c'est un des points
qu'on a qu'on a mis en place au même
titre qu'il existe des référents égalité
il faudrait des référents prévention
voilà dans les entreprises donc on a
réussi à le faire pour l'égalité on
pourrait très bien le faire pour la
santé là on s'est focusé santé de la
femme certes vous vous doutez bien que
ce genre de propositions sont mixte bien
sûr et bénéficie à tous
la prévention des récidives après une
longue maladie et après un congé
maternité compliqué est aussi une des
demandes que l'on a faite pour les
employeurs qu'il y ait quelque chose
vraiment de demander et de mis en place
dans ce cadre-là un retour de maternité
compliqué c'est compliqué et c'est sur
le dos de la femme voilà ça c'est dans
les statistiques c'est même pas une
question d'opinion
afin d'inciter les employeurs à tonir
compte de la singularité féminine dans
la santé là il y a tout un levier qui
est complexe
un employeur qui parle de la santé des
femmes c'est tellement tabou que les
femmes qui prônent l'égalité ne veulent
parfois pas en entendre parler
et en même temps il le faut parce qu'il
y a une singularité de la femme dans la
santé et c'est tout cette ambiguïté
autour de la parole qu'on met dans les
entreprises avec le rôle de l'employeur
qui doit être travaillé discutée et pour
lequel on a un besoin vraiment de
coopération
en ce qui concerne des demandes que nous
avions en direction des pouvoirs publics
en pensant que c'était plutôt de l'ordre
des pouvoirs publics il est nécessaire
de mettre en place une macroé une macro
étude économique qui montre le bénéfice
des préventions au sein de l'entreprise
par rapport au fait de pas le faire avec
une entreprise pilote
il y a un moment il faut quand même
regarder chose en face on va pas dans la
prévention quand on est employeur parce
qu'on a peur que ça coûte de l'argent
sauf qu'en fait le bénéfice il est réel
on le sait on en entend parler tout le
monde le dit sauf qu'il y a jamais eu
une Neptune économique qui la trouve
qu'il a trouvé il y a les moyens on a la
méthode on sait faire les études
macroéconomiques faut juste les mettre
en place une fois qu'on a montré que
c'est efficace et que c'est une économie
que pour l'entreprise déjà on a un
argument
qui contre la performance cet argument
qui est en remonté pour dire mais vous
vous trompez ensuite
clarifier le rôle et les missions de la
médecine du travail mériterait d'être
mis en place on sait qu'il y a des
guerres entre les entre les groupes de
médecine disons le clairement et il y a
notamment vous le savez les trois
rendez-vous de prévention qui ne sont
pas des consultations qui sont des
rendez-vous de prévention qui peuvent
donner lieu à une consultation quel est
le rôle de la médecine de travail dans
ces trois rendez-vous de prévention on
sait que pour l'instant les moyens pour
les mettre en oeuvre il y a déjà les
médecins sont déjà noyés les gens sur le
terrain sont déjà noyés quel est le rôle
de la médecine de la prévention
là-dessus la médecine du travail pardon
c'est un lapsus mais elles auraient son
jeu à jouer et puis on parle beaucoup de
la femme au travail on a oublié ici on y
a pensé les femmes qui ne travaillent
pas
les failles qui ne travaillent pas et
ben elles vont pas non plus dans la
santé elles y vont pas parce que du coup
elles peuvent pas y aller parce qu'en
général si elle travaille pas c'est
qu'elle s'occupe de leurs enfants et que
quand elles ont des rendez-vous
prévention elles n'y vont pas non plus
et donc il serait bien mais que la CAF
organise un système pour qu'elle puisse
aller faire leurs examens quand elles
doivent le faire
on les oublie souvent enfin
on demande que dans toutes les
politiques publiques
dans toutes les politiques de prévention
il y a un indicateur charge mentale
c'est-à-dire que quand on pense un
système de prévention quand on pense une
campagne de prévention quand on pense à
un dispositif de prévention on pense
l'indicateur charge mentale qu'est-ce
qu'on fait est-ce que ce que je propose
encore à lui en dire la charge mentale
ou pas et si oui bah ça veut dire que je
vais proposer quelque chose avec
énormément de trous dans la raquette et
qu'une bonne partie des familles iront
pas dans cette prévention
le deuxième atelier j'en ai fini avec
ces recommandations là et après je vais
juste rebondir sur la lettre ouverte et
après j'en aurai fini
on demande pour libérer ses tabous la
bonne information au bon moment pour le
bon choix on sait maintenant que la
plupart des femmes qui ont un cancer
comprennent absolument rien leur maladie
et que celles qui ont un traitement
comprennent pas leur traitement et on
sait aussi que aucun médecin quasiment
ça c'est des rapports des femmes de
santé alors effectivement je suis
caricatural c'est pas aucune et c'est
pas très peu mais beaucoup et les
associations de patientes reçoivent des
patientes qui ne comprennent pas leur
maladie on va dire comme ça c'est plus
c'est plus juste
on ne leur pose pas la question dans le
cadre du soin qu'avez-vous compris de
votre maladie on ne leur pose pas la
question dans le cadre du soin
qu'avez-vous pensé de votre retraitement
donc la reformulation n'est pas proposée
j'insiste là-dessus
c'était juste une parenthèse sur la
santé de la femme ce qu'on propose nous
donc c'est pas dans ce cadre enfin c'est
dans ce cadre là mais c'est pas dans le
travail c'est qu'il y ait une campagne
de communication pour faire pour prendre
conscience à toutes et à tous de ce que
sont les tabous autour de la santé de la
femme pour pouvoir les libérer dans le
travail
pour pouvoir les libérer dans le cadre
des soins et pour pouvoir les libérer
pour les hommes
donc dans ce cadre-là la libération des
tabous on la souhaite Pioneer chez les
femmes et ce serait une campagne de
communication qui montrerait des
symptômes tabous chez les femmes qui en
parlent entre elles et qui dirait ben
non c'est pas normal en d'autres termes
j'ai fait je viens d'éternuer je viens
de me faire pipi dessus c'est normal
dans la famille tout le monde se pisse
dessus bah non c'est pas normal voilà ça
c'est un exemple de tabou le moins le
plus facile à dire et je n'évoquerai pas
les autres pour finir cette lettre
ouverte qui souhaite une stratégie
nationale dans cette stratégie nationale
doivent participer l'ensemble des
acteurs de la société on a tendance et
ça c'est une demande des femmes de santé
à dire que quand on travaille de la
santé on va inviter des associations de
patients déjà c'est mieux qu'avant
on va inviter les autorités de santé on
va inviter des soignants mais on va
zapper complètement et définitivement
les employeurs mais même des employeurs
qui ne sont pas du secteur des
employeurs de l'industrie des employeurs
de la de n'importe quel secteur de la
santé de l'annonce santé ils doivent
être parti prenantes dans une stratégie
nationale santé de la femme pourquoi
parce que les femmes représentent 50% de
la population parce que la manifeste la
banalisation des manifestations
cliniques demeure parce que les biais
genre et prise en charge dans les prises
en charge demeure parce que la charge
mentale pèse sur les femmes parce qu'on
s'est désormais que les maladies mixtes
ne s'expriment pas de la même façon chez
les deux
parce que beaucoup de femmes leur parole
ce ne sont pas entendues et leurs
paroles complètement minorée parce que
les errances diagnostiques sont trop
nombreuses parce que la recherche
épidémiaux les données récoltées les
essais cliniques ne sont pas enrés on
l'a vu sur d'autres secteurs on l'a vu
dans le cadre de la de la santé au
travail mais ce n'est pas que là-dedans
enfin des recherches épidémies sont pas
genre quand même dans la plupart des cas
on les a les statistiques et de dire que
c'est compliqué de gens on a les stats
ou alors maintenant on peut juste
demander une croix de genre dans
l'ensemble des questionnaires qu'on fait
c'est pas un surmontable les
spécialistes de la santé de la femme
sont aussi trop peu nombreux les tabous
on l'a vu demeure on sait désormais
aussi que l'ensemble de ces points là
sont essentiels les biais genre
réinconscients dans tous les secteurs
professionnels sont présents la
caricature des femmes est présente la
recherche de la santé de la femme prise
dans sa globalité n'existe pas et n'a
jamais été aborder on plane complet en
fait et c'est ce dont on se sont aperçus
l'ensemble des femmes de santé et quand
je parle des femmes de santé je parle de
toutes les femmes qu'elles soient
avocats de la santé start-upeuse
professeur des universités chercheuses
médecin de terrain
infirmière en libérale peu importe on
sait tout rendu compte lors de ses états
généraux qu'en fait on n'avait pas pensé
à une santé de la femme
il n'y a pas de programme national santé
de la femme et si on salue le programme
la stratégie nationale endométriose elle
est thématisée il y a énormément
d'autres symptômes féminins qui sont
complètement abandonnés laissés de côté
et ignorer il n'y a pas que
l'endométriose il n'y a pas que des
symptômes de la sphère gynécologique la
première cause de mortalité chez les
femmes c'est les accidents vasculaires
cérébraux je vous remercie j'ai été un
peu longue mais j'insiste vraiment sur
le fait que tous doivent être inclus
quand on parle de la santé des femmes y
compris les employeurs qui ne viennent
pas du secteur de la santé
[Musique]